[Música]
y es que nuestro segundo invitado el día
olivier brochette él es director de la
agencia para la enseñanza francesa en el
extranjero brochette realizó una visita
a bogotá colombia con el motivo de la
inauguración del instituto regional de
formación y también nuestra periodista
andrea maya conversó con él veamos la
entrevista que les realizó
bienvenidos a france24
en esta ocasión nos encontramos con
olivia y vice director de la agencia
para la educación francesa en el
extranjero se trata de un
establecimiento público que coordina una
extensa red de instituciones educativas
francesas en todo el mundo y esta red ya
cuenta con 552 establecimientos soliz y
dos franceses distribuidos en 138 países
buenos días
empecemos con la agencia para la
enseñanza francesa en el extranjero
explíquenos de qué se trata esta agencia
por los dos polos la agencia para la
enseñanza francesa en el extranjero es
un establecimiento público del estado
que depende del ministerio europeo y de
asuntos exteriores francés que se
encarga de coordinar y dirigir el
conjunto de la enseñanza francesa en el
extranjero
como usted lo dijo la red de la
enseñanza francesa en el extranjero se
compone de 552 establecimientos en 138
países
es la red educativa internacional más
grande del mundo organizada por un
estado controlada por un estado así que
la agencia se encarga de mantener viva
esa reducción de controlar su calidad en
el marco de la homologación para todos
estos establecimientos otorgada por el
ministerio de educación nacional francés
y además de mantener viva en todos estos
establecimientos la educación a la
francesa que ofrecemos a las familias
que buscan una enseñanza internacional
de alta calidad
en 2018 el presidente francés y manuel
mccomb estableció un objetivo llamado
cap 2030 para duplicar la cantidad de
alumnos en los liceos franceses en el
extranjero
como aumentará la agencia de esta
cantidad de en 2022
dado que todavía hay una pandemia de
kobe 19 que ha obligado a muchas
familias a ahorrar dinero
con el crecimiento que el presidente de
la república nos pidió estimular y
acompañar está presente a pesar de la
crisis sanitaria que hemos vivido
cuando el presidente de la república se
pronunció en marzo de 2018 había
495 establecimientos de enseñanza
francesa en el extranjero
hoy en día hay 552 así que ya vemos más
de 60 establecimientos adicionales la
cantidad de alumnos desde 2018 ha subido
casi 40 mil alumnos adicionales en la
red así que la dinámica está ahí por
supuesto se vio frenada por la pandemia
pero se reactivó desde la entrada a
clases en septiembre pasado y hemos
tenido un crecimiento de la función en
la red de más de 2%
lo curioso para contestar a su pregunta
sobre la manera en la que lo hacemos
admisión ero es darle a conocer la
enseñanza francesa en el extranjero a
las familias que no nos conocen familias
que buscan una enseñanza internacional
de calidad controlada' certificada por
un estado que invierte mucho en la
educación
así que hay todo un trabajo de
comunicación sobre lo que es esta
enseñanza
segundo eje es el fortalecimiento de las
cualidades de esta enseñanza
trabajamos mucho en el fortalecimiento
de la escuela maternal
que es la escuela a través de la cual
entran los niños más pequeños es una
particularidad francesa
pero trabajamos en ella por su calidad
trabajamos por desarrollar el
plurilingüismo de nuestros colegios son
colegios francófonos por supuesto pero
pluri hill es un alumno que pasa por la
enseñanza francesa es un alumno que al
momento de presentar su examen de bacalo
gear hablará al menos tres incluso
cuatro idiomas perfectamente y para
nosotros eso es una apuesta muy
importante además la enseñanza del
francés en el extranjero tiene valores
fuertes valores educativos que
incorporamos sobre la igualdad entre
niños y niñas sobre el desarrollo del
espíritu crítico de nuestros alumnos
para que se conviertan en ciudadanos
ilustrados de modo futuro esos son los
grandes ejes y hay otro eje fundamental
para nosotros que es la formación de
nuestros profesores justamente en
relación con los profesores este año la
agencia creó 16 institutos regionales de
formación o 'los y rf fuentes de qué se
trata esta estructura cuál es la novedad
y también porque hay una sede aquí en
bogotá
decidimos crear 16 institutos regionales
de formación en el mundo estábamos
organizados por zonas de formación pero
quisimos fortalecer nuestra capacidad de
formación en términos cualitativos y
cuantitativos
y cualitativos porque con el desarrollo
de la red debemos formar cada vez más
profesores larreta y profesores que
vienen de francia pero no son
suficientes
así que debemos formar profesores que
contratamos localmente que los
establecimientos contratan localmente y
que deben estar formados en la enseñanza
francesa esto quiere decir que hablen
francés esa es la base pero además que
manejen las prácticas pedagógicas
francesas que las dominen bien y que
también sean portadores de esos valores
que versiones
así que fortalecemos un gran trabajo
cualitativo y también cuantitativo
porque debemos formar cada vez más
miembros
los fieles nacen a partir de ciertas
necesidades expresadas por los
profesores de los liceos franceses
cuáles son exactamente esas necesidades
que se han identificado en nuestro
programa de formación está organizado en
16 zonas del mundo porque las
necesidades de formación son muy
diferentes dependiendo de si se está
aquí en bogotá hay madagascar en tokio o
en el viento
las necesidades de formación son muy
diferentes porque el personal es muy
diferente a los orígenes son diferentes
así que es necesario contextualizar la
formación
trabajamos con base en los programas de
formación establecidos por la educación
nacional francesa así que debemos
asegurarnos de que los profesores
dominen por completo el conjunto de
competencias exigidas por la educación
nacional para que el establecimiento sea
reconocido como un establecimiento de
enseñanza francesa pero también le
pedimos a cada uno de los
establecimientos que piense en su
estrategia de formación respecto al
personal que tiene en su establecimiento
pero también respecto a su proyecto como
establecimiento así deben una demanda de
formación que el jefe debe satisfacer a
través de la construcción de un plan de
formación adaptado a las necesidades de
los establecimientos es a través de ese
diálogo ld efe y todos los
establecimientos de la zona cómo se
construye el plan de formación
en otros términos los y rf son una
inversión que la agencia hace en su
personal los profesores
pero si hablamos sobre los alumnos
hace un momento hablábamos sobre las
becas económicas para algunos alumnos o
becas del gobierno francés
como hacen en ese sentido en un país
como colombia donde la educación de
calidad es bastante cara como por
ejemplo la educación en los liceos
internacionales
el sistema de becas gestionado por la
agencia es un sistema de becas para los
alumnos de nacionalidad francesa
para todos los alumnos franceses que
viven en países extranjeros si no tienen
los medios de financiación para acceder
a un colegio pueden obtener una beca del
gobierno francés
para los nacionales que quieren hacer
parte de nuestros colegios muchos
establecimientos tienen su propio
sistema de ayuda económica para
favorecer a las familias
con la crisis que hemos vivido durante
la pandemia el gobierno francés decidió
temporalmente darle una ayuda a las
familias nacionales que ya estaban
matriculadas que tenían dificultades
en el marco del plan de emergencia
durante la crisis pandémica el gobierno
francés puso 100 millones de euros a
disposición de la agencia
para apoyar a todos los establecimientos
y a todas las familias sin distinción
franceses extranjeros y gracias a ello
pudimos mantener la mayor parte de las
familias dentro de la formación incluso
nos proponían dificultades económicas
también tenemos un sistema de becas de
excelencia para los mejores alumnos
extranjeros que están en nuestra red
para que luego vayan a estudiar a
francia son las becas de excelencia
mayor reservadas cada año varios alumnos
colombianos se benefician de ellas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
gracias ya sabes los invito a que sigan
con nosotros en france 24 la entrevista
entonces que le hizo nuestra periodista
andrea maya a olivia broche espero que
le hayan disfrutado tanto como nosotros
continúe hay mucho más para ver aquí en
directo américa
[Música]